[Music]
forty-three seconds of logos I'm
wondering is this a film production
company or is it a request reading wait
what
okay I know the books don't matter and
they apparently didn't do for this
movies box office but this is a
legendary series and they boiled it down
to two half-assed title cards that
barely have anything to do with the
gunslingers story Marty angry at this
movie's laziness it's not even two
minutes into it this obvious Easter Egg
featuring the discount The Shining twins
tells you everything you need to know
about how hard this movie's gonna try
what is it with these science fiction
planets and multiple moons this close to
the planet but everything somehow turned
out to be like earth good news if you
were coming into your Dark Tower
experience expecting another Saw movie
you're in luck damn there goes on the
run again the planet can't catch a break
in any universe also I'm sorry when this
movie told me that the mind of a child
could bring the Dark Tower down I didn't
realize it was so fucking literal I
thought it meant a kid's imagination or
something so simple a child could think
of it but literal laser beam shot out of
children's heads what is causing all
these earthquakes Christ even espn's to
increase them sorry asshole stepdad
template character but there's no can
way that's ESPN considering there's only
the bottom crawl and no other adornment
so while it may be ESPN in your mind
this movie wasn't willing to pay for it
to be featured so ends the apocalypse
coming damn at this point I'd be shocked
if I ever saw a movie based on a Stephen
King book that doesn't feature a kid
getting bullied you know instead of
going to the principal or encountering
any consequences for your physical
assault on this asshole why would this
child psychologist have a random framed
picture of the Overlook from The Shining
in his office this New York Post
headline is about a gas explosion that
killed five people but the story is
about a blackout that killed 78 I know
that the collapse of the Dark Tower is
supposed to bring darkness and fire but
I didn't know it brought mismatched
articles involving both of those things
also nostalgia exposition meanwhile and
Maze Runner Thomas and Teresa are trying
to figure out what went wrong after
baking those cookies had forgotten the
face of his father the fact that Rowland
and his dad say this out loud seems
counterintuitive to the whole we're
being hunted so maybe we should be
pretty quiet strategy stop breathing
these are highly trained gunslingers
here and sure well
powerful but neither Stephen nor Rowland
fired off one shot at Walter as soon as
he says stop it never works on new
desert Roland the power you have to
resist my magics look Microsoft Word
doesn't give me a red squiggly line when
I write the magics my brain sure did
when I heard Matthew McConaughey say it
until next time old friend okay I
understand this is a sequel or a
spin-off for a different universe or
some both other than the Dark Tower
series
so maybe Roland's already very familiar
with Walter and his shenanigans but in
the movie version could he'd not go
after him right now and either try to
talk to him or can kill him Jesus Christ
man impact across the desert
yep that was the first line of the
gunslinger sure I'm glad I'm being read
that line for nostalgia sake and not I
don't know seeing it in action on screen
which is the point of a goddamn movie
hey this guy is some kind of soldier
he's called a gunslinger
Jake who knows for a fact that his
friend to me doesn't believe this knocks
on his door and starts rambling about a
drawing I realize this is so we know
what these drawings mean but could we
just hear the thoughts in his head
rather than have him explain this to a
disinterested third party it's fun
listen pretty sure Jake's mom's only
character traits were listed as
disbelieving exasperated and ha you're
gonna go with them right now or I swear
to God I won't drive you down the stairs
myself since this is technically a story
about the destruction of New York the
movies kind enough to provide us with a
roland emmerich father figure
considering what we've seen of Jake so
far does being Jason Bourne fit his
character
[Applause]
[Music]
this device which helps transport people
to different places in the universe uses
1990s modem sounds when it powers on all
so how did the device know to power on
does it sense the kids with abilities
because if it doesn't this universe
travelling device is available to any
Boo Radley in Brooklyn this movie is way
more trauma legacy than I think it
intended not to be confused with Middle
Earth or Midgard your pink shoe look
there's like a million pieces of scrap
lumber around here that you could have
thrown through the portal and you went
with your fucking shoe what the
explanation is given for the house demon
trying to eat Jake here other than a
cheap excuse for some special effects if
there were security measures in place
how the hell was it so easy for him to
open the portal portal takes Jake to a
place that really really sucks why would
you travel with this place only to have
to walk through a desert for many days
until you find food and water and a
reason to live movies only an hour and
35 minutes but has time for Jake to get
briefly chased by an internet meme no
candidate female age 11 by the way I'm
wondering I go through all the business
with pretending you're from some
psychology camp to abduct these kids why
not just take them and drive off in a
van to the next portal welcome back soon
how was your trip fine do you have any
new leads movie takes the fearsome
character of the man in black and
reduces him to a discount lost target
unauthorized crossing sir one of the old
portals on Keystone earth-like keystone
earth why not just name the planet
something else does putting Keystone in
front of it make it a different name or
just show how lazy you are love you
mattes choose a pretty face in the world
is your oyster lining sir
boy this movie sure really wants to
emphasize the portals and wrap people
and bad parenting really anything other
than the central gunslinger character
also
it's amazing that Jake found the one
portal that was not only lined up with
New York but was also pointed pretty
directly at Rowan with minimal walking
required I guess that portal was also
aware of the movie's runtime who is he
he's a sorcerer huh I guess Jake thought
Walter would be played by a late 90s era
Sean William Scott this is tribe yelling
that forest will go there have Sears who
will read your visions Roland is looking
for Walter and he stumbles on a kid with
visions out in the middle of the desert
and just so happens to be within miles
of a tribe full of prophets who can
interpret those visions if we were
following role in this whole time this
would be a deus ex machina of the
highest order and we're sitting it as
such hate neglecting the fact that this
is a dick move if this is possible I
don't know why the man in black has
anything
like a conflict in his life enough is he
using a handkerchief to pick this up see
worried about the chain of evidence
Matthew McConaughey is playing a true
detective here because he is Dazed and
Confused didn't one of his employees
already tell him that a portal was used
on Keystone Earth and if they know it
was used wouldn't they know where it
sent him so this is where the rat people
congregate and get their human masks but
it's got this on the door
ever heard of subtlety house demons are
formidable beings with a truly powerful
psychic could override it too bad we
didn't just put a lock somewhere so he
couldn't access the console in the first
place but these house demons unionize
back in 76 and they're hard to terminate
without going through years of
bureaucracy and red tape mm-hmm advise
you me boy shine as pure oh it sure is
cool meeting all these new characters
that have abilities that are specific to
the plot and are not further explained
in any way whoa it's a shine strong
enough to kill a demon movie definitely
ties into the shining which normally I
would celebrate but it really just makes
me want to watch The Shining Sarah
didn't two skins have trouble with her
kid yesterday why is this information
just now getting the Walter King
seriously the next scene will probably
have a reference to misery then they'll
find a way to stick the shawshank
redemption' in here and if this movie is
just long enough maybe Christine will
make it by the what an amusement park be
located out in the goddamn forest and if
the movies saying the world has moved on
why is all this carnival still here
relatively intact all these trees had
time to grow but the marquee maintained
its structure well and damn it kid you
had one job if you get murdered by feral
inhabitants of a weird landscape it's on
you for not keeping the hell up with
Roland so you fight him how's the fields
covered with bodies in when we saw the
field covered in bodies but Walter just
walked up and set a dude on fire
damn it movie if you're gonna reference
something at least give us a proper King
reference such an honor to meet you in
person sir I'm sorry but does Walter
seem like the kind of guy who tells his
underlings hey let's go get a burger
when he needs information location it's
all in here magical whack job Walter
needs a fucking dossier in order to find
a child even though he's been shown to
be pretty much omnipotent up until now
outside his endless darkness full of
demons thoughts of us it's hair down the
tower when the tower falls he'll roar
why does he need the demons to rule he's
already shown that he can get into
people's heads and make them do what he
wants and what makes him so sure that he
can control the demons when they arrive
what exactly this Walter actually want
when he rules the universe what kind of
life can he have then that he can't have
now
so how often are they taking shots at
the tower the last time this happened it
cost massive damage and these kids have
obviously been around for a while so the
tower should already be in putting
shambles if Roland has such a killin
boner for Walter why isn't he chasing
the source of the death ray which he can
clearly see and since it's happened at
least a few times before what the fuck's
taking him so long hey kiddo movie has a
discount contact moment that's even less
necessary than the actual contact
darkness and fire so Roland tells Jake
that every time the tower is hit a small
tear opens and the demons try to go
through it but how do they camouflage
the red barrier while they impersonate
Jake's dead dad this is still a
protective barrier created by the dark
tower correct and if this is just an
illusion for Jake then why doesn't roll
and see the barrier when he's looking
for Sonny got out if this small terror
happens every time then how come there
aren't actual demons on earth wreaking
havoc right now everybody's gonna be so
lucky to have rolling around unless this
movie's saying the demons only show up
on this planet so great it's chronic
because you've shot at it with a regular
s gun that's a shapeless demon it should
be boom you dat you firing at it moody
couldn't decide between dark and out of
the scene or massive amounts of cuts
that's the best strategy for obfuscating
it's CGI and said let's do both he
handled yourself well really what
impressed you the part when Jake didn't
pick up the gun or the part when he ran
around and almost got impaled several
times I hope you don't mind me making
myself at home where I come from we
don't have chicken and you really get
the sense Matthew McConaughey had no
clue about this character just trying a
different way to play Walter in every
scene also if this scenes being played
for laughs the movie hasn't set up
Walter to be this kind of comic relief
if he's doing this to lull Jake's
parents into thinking he's normal while
breaking in and cooking chicken doesn't
quite work if he's genuinely hungry and
wants to eat chicken why didn't he just
stopped by a KFC before he came here I'd
rather see the cliche where the bad guy
listen to classical music and what
Jake's stepdad says who are you Walter
could just hold up his index finger
indicating a good part is about to come
up and he'd rather not be interrupted
during it trying's but what about the
chicken you were putting spices on that
meal is going to burn the kilt you must
feel
not believing in him but she still
doesn't know all that was true right all
Walters done is show up cook a chicken
and kill Jake stepdad so she's probably
really feeling more know away by the
breaking-and-entering than guilty I know
Rowan's tired and injured injured but
there is no urgency by his character to
hunt and kill Walter the first half of
this movie is a lot of this sitting
around and doing nominal instead of
being singularly focused on that magical
bastard and do something where is this
child he's here on mid world if you
didn't know that before you left how do
you know that now are you telling me
that by walking into his room you got
some sort of psychic scent and if so why
couldn't you get that same scent when
you visited the house where he
transported the only way to access their
territories is from one of their own
bases goddamn this random small-town
seer sure does know a lot about the
inner workings of a cabal that's trying
to destroy the tower do they put out a
weekly press release does everyone else
as soon as it aligns it should open an
unobstructed barrier in your city on
your version of Earth aside from the
Pennywise thing is this the first time
the movie has even acknowledged two
different versions of earth sure they
called earth Keystone Earth earlier but
there's never been one mention of a
version of Earth and how that works for
the whole movie I guess this first
assholes job was to stand there and look
intimidating so that the other asshole
can give this villager a proper
backstabbing Walter pulls a magic marble
out of his collection and puts it on a
thing which then gives him this B
hologram to watch do you think the fine
marble would translate into a picture
quality that's better than a vic-20
computer but you'd be wrong also why is
it Walter on this mission to capture the
KITT since Jake is so special you think
someone like Walter would want to be
dick in case anything goes wrong
especially considering what he believes
Jake is capable of hang on Walter's
minions said they were gonna send our
trackers in the region sir boom I guess
we're on vacation and only pillagers
were available this attack started
without us knowing exactly who these rat
people are or anything about their
abilities we barely even know anything
about the people in this village who's
seen his dark moves around to multiple
locations and his flash edited to death
this movie itself is probably telling
the director get on to the next scene
already so have they fired the guy that
suggested that the Dark Tower movie
should include a bunch of orcs punching
stringer Bell yet what are you doing
quiet so wait he can't tune her out but
he can tune out all the other loud noise
that's going on around him so that he
can hear Jake's abductor running away
I like how this whole scene is
contingent upon Roland being able to
tune into Jake's frequency and being
able to sonar his abductors height from
100 yards away at the movie focused on
Roland instead of trying to be the next
divergent mais potter wiii be able to
understand his abilities better as is
the movie forces you to swallow how
impossible this shot is without a bit of
context come on Walter alerted all those
trackers where Jake was when he started
to shine which led to his capture in the
first place so why aren't the rest of
them attacking them right now when
they're walking through the middle of
the fucking village look I know they
fixed this thing using spare parts or
something but before the attack it took
forever for this portal power up so
you're telling me that during this
attack they were able to fix the machine
no problem and were able to power it up
in record time I think they're gone but
Walter was watching the whole thing
unfold on his magic ball vision thing
did he just turn that off immediately
after the first tracker picked up Jake I
see the eyes of all six are kicking in
apparently a stab wound from an evil
demon from the nothing will respond to
regular antibiotics what is this
sugar so is this a product on placement
or is it the unproductive how are you
gonna find the portal New York's a
pretty big place can't you just have a
vision about it there was no real rhyme
or reason as to why your shine gave you
a vision of the other one since it was
apparently a house run by Walter and his
minions so why hasn't it given you
directions to the new portal
Keystone Earth all you have to do is
search an entire planet you're sure to
find Jake in a matter of hours I know I
know
New York is the base of operations on
earth but why is it the only one you're
trying to cast this wide net to find
children with abilities and you narrow
it down to just New York hey remember me
fancy that they found that homeless guy
from earlier one of the not even though
his vision comes in well after he
notices the ashes Jake somehow
immediately knows those ashes are his
mom this one he's tracking you Walter
has trackers all over the city
but he has nobody at Jake's home address
and he knows Jake and Roland are on
Keystone Earth so why isn't he already
here god damn this movie and its
inability to logic what about the tower
funny the screenwriters asked this
question after realizing they'd written
75% of a Dark Tower movie that has very
little dark towering in it I am I look I
know New York City has its crime
problems but they're in lower fucking
Manhattan shooting incredibly loud guns
in a warehouse and nobody notices did
you miss me
so Walter is projecting himself inside
this gun store using one of his fancy
marbles if you can make a projection
like this look so good why were the
images for the village attack a certain
shade of hologram puke-green fire away
it's not me not doing this since when do
any other people Walter possesses know
that their actions are not their own and
considering the command why would he
stop to tell him this when everything in
his body should be compelling him to
repeatedly fire that gun at rolling Oh
so Walter his minions do employ
windowless vans for abductions why did
they try that other method again damn
looks like Jake's got a super-high
midi-chlorian count of course no movie
is complete without the everyone runs to
get their guns from the weapons Locker
scene I guess he's out of bullets then
and since when is the gunslinger the
Incredible Hulk
I know Roland is a badass gunslinger and
there's no way he's gonna die but there
were a million henchmen all over the
place with automatic rifles and the fact
that they stopped shooting as soon as
Roland appears allowing him to take them
all out with two six-shooters takes me
right out of this can movie roland
briefly becomes Batman in the middle of
this fight was this asshole expecting to
happen now I have to put up with the non
comic-book movies
Roland not only survives this but the
bus driver continues to drive oh my god
it's the kid he's keeping the portal
open keep in mind that jake has had very
little chance to hone his shining skills
but sure he can keep the portal open
using only his mine I thought shine was
more psychic than telekinetic but it's a
movie so I should really just relax I
guess also wow that magical
technological doohickey that focuses the
kids power sure is handy for also
telling you who's keeping a portal open
this movie
Rowland does not shooter aim with his
hand nor does he kill with his gun
because something something is Father's
face so how come the bullets are hitting
rocks and not the spaces between the
rocks I mean this is a cool sift trick
being played by Walter but it has about
an 85 percent chance of putting this all
up
also Darth Watterson Louie makes it seem
like this would be any worse than
crashing through a window and falling a
couple stories into a bus which is
something that definitely happened two
minutes ago
anyway Roland survives us to kill this
Mike on during this long long long
gunslingers creed scene Walther
apparently can't walk 20 feet to
officially end roll it wait does
reciting the gunslinger creed make the
second bullet travel faster than the
first bullet when your facility is
primed to explode just because the mind
control machine takes a bullet you chose
the wrong architect so I guess all those
children that were living in the village
directly next to this exploding building
or dead in this happy ending
don't you come with me you have nothing
here stuff man I know his mom's dead and
all but Jake still has like grandparents
and aunts and uncles and friends and
maybe at least stop by the apartment to
get his toothbrush
you're gonna go with them right now or I
swear to God I will drag you down the
stairs myself well you know my name is
Simon and I like to do drawings who
throws a shoe honestly
[Music]
do have any new leads and what the good
leaves are the Glengarry leads to leads
a hundred bucks hey kiddo really yes my
dear
[Music]
you
[Applause]
you see her eating broken body soaked in
her blood
now how imagine she's white immediately
regret this decision
let the heat flow through you